اتممنا بالسفه التامه
اجلاء الرعايه
السعوديين
والرعايه الدول الخليج بسفرائهم منذ ثلاثه
ايام وصلوا بحمد الله الى
المملكه بيسر وسلامه
ولكن هناك بعض السعوديين الذين يتواصلون
معنا ولم نكن على علم بهم وهم في عدد من
الولايات السودانيه ونتخذ الاجراءات
اللازمه في ترحيلهم منذ ان عرفنا
بمقرات تواجدهم وعديد منهم قادر الامس
بالليل
واما عمليه الاجلاب بصفه عامه فهي مستمره
لكل
الرعايه الاجانب
الذين طلبت دولهم ان
تقوم المملكه بمساعدتهم بالاجلاء والوصول
الى مدينه جده ما هي ابرز الدول التي
انطلبت ان تنسق معها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه حتى تجلي بحكم
الامكانيات بحكم القرب ما هي ابرز هذه
الدول
حقيقه معظم الدول
غربيه وعربيه واسيويه
فمثلا
رجلين الرعايه امريكان بريطانيين
ايرانديين
وغيرهم ثم
وصلتهم رغبات من
المغرب وتونس وموريتانيا
والجزائر والباكستان وتايلاند واليابان
وماليزيا وهذا
ورعاياهم البعض منهم وصل واجلناه والبعض
سيتم خلال هذه الليله
والايام القادمه اجلاهم بالسلام ان شاء
الله الليله ان شاء الله ستغادر سفينه
بحموله 2500 شخص
من مختلف الجنسيات نحن
جهزنا على مدار 24 ساعه
طاقم سعودي
لاستقبال
وتجهيز وانهاء جوازات الاجراءات الرسميه
للاجلاء
سواء هنا في هذا المقر او
بالتعاون مع اجهزه الشرطه السودانيه
هذه المناسبه اود ان ارفع
ما وصلني من شكر وتقدير
كل سفراء ورعايه الدول التي اجليناها او
الدول المتوقع اجلال رعاياها
للقياده الحكيمه
ولما قدمته المملكه من يسر وتيسير
لاجلاء مواطنيها الى المملكه والتعاون
والتنسيق في داخل المملكه ما بين
اللجان السعوديه الرسميه
المكلفه بالاجراء وسفرات هذه الدول
هل من جهد متوقع للمملكه والرباعيه
الدوليه في تهدئه الاوضاع في السودان اخي
العزيز
الجهود
المجموعه الرباعيه الاليه الثلاثيه لم
تتوقف لحظه
قبل الاندلاع الاعمال القتاليه وبعدها وما
زلنا
ولعلك تعرف انه كان هناك دنتين كانت بسبب
العمل ادوا
للمجموعه الرباعيه والاليه الثلاثيه
ومواطنين سودانيين
وجدوا من
مصلحه الوطن ان يكون هناك
تحديه وان شاء الله ما زال العمل مستمر
للوصول الى وقف الاطلاق النار والعوده الى
الحوار لان الحوار هو الاساس الذي سيحقق
ان شاء الله تطلعات الشعب السوداني في
السودان مستقر وموحد باذن الله
الطبيعه نحن الان في تواصل مع الطرفين
هم من الاول هو ايقاف اطلاق النار بعد ذاك
سنبحث الخطوه التاليه ان شاء الله
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات